you have to think about the fact that
not everyone in the world is going to
see constellations the same way or if
you're on drugs that you'll see them
not everybody
I'm certain that the Greeks were on
something for half the constellations
that they named oh my God they must have
been they must have been
[Music]
this is Star Talk
osmic queries Edition ever popular with
all of our audiences and I got with me
my co-host today Matt Kirsch and Matt
welcome back to Star Talk thanks Nils
good to see you so Matt your host uh
probably science that was a one-time
guest on there and absolutely I'm
waiting for you I will yeah I'd love you
to come back still one of our most
popular episodes okay so today our topic
is like
folklore in astrophysics it's like and
how do they relate and who connects a
line between modern or even ancient
astrophysics and cultures and folklore
this is like there aren't many people
who do this and when you think about it
you know the sky was really accessible
to everyone at all times
forever right I mean unless it was
cloudy but cave cave dwellers saw the
night sky so of all the Sciences uh
modern astronomy and of course
astrophysics would have connections that
maybe other Sciences don't so if
anyone's going to tackle this it's going
to be on Star talk and we have an expert
in this in the name of Moya mcteer Moya
welcome to start talk hi Neil thanks for
having me this is a goal of mine it has
been for a long time I'm really happy to
be here thank you so you're an
astrophysicist A folklorist and A
Communicator I love that that can be a
title today because it's so necessary to
move information and knowledge and
wisdom from one place to another that
requires communicators and so you you
have your own podcast podcasts
excuse me okay podcasts tell me their
names
uh so the one that is my my favorite
brain baby probably just because it's
oldest is called EXO lore it's a
portmanteau actually of exoplanets and
folklore because the whole
schtick of the show is building
fictional worlds based on facts and
science usually that means I start with
some astronomical difference like what
if this planet didn't orbit a star and
we know that those types of planets
exist they're called rogue planets there
are probably tens of thousands of them
out there or what if a planet had two
sons or what if it got hit with
asteroids all the time and then we just
imagine the consequences of that
difference my other podcast is more
straightforward more obviously about
science and it's called pale blue pod
it's actually quite new it just launched
in November and it's a show for November
2022 yeah of 2022 yeah so it's a little
baby and it is a show for people who are
overwhelmed by the universe but still
want to be its friend and I have I've
taken some notes on your your show and
the way that you do things I have a
comedian co-host her name is Corinne
Caputo she's very funny very smart but
the whole vibe of the show is extremely
cozy we want to make space feel very
warm and familiar for people oh so the
microphones are closest it welcome to
pale blue pod
can we get very ASMR yeah yeah
both of you just then like there are
some listeners who got properly tingly
right then and
you're welcome you're welcome
this is the universe yes I love it I
love it so tell us about your your this
this strand This Thread that multiple
threads that you've woven to connect
astrophysics which was one half of your
major in college to Folklore
yeah let me let me tell you a bit about
how I came to major in both of those
things because you you might know this
Neil having gone to Harvard yourself but
you there's a pre-approved list of
double majors at Harvard and they're
they're normal things like government
and econ or psychology and computer
science surprisingly astrophysics and
vocal or mythology not on that list of
stuff that Harvard administrators
thought people would want to study
together so I actually had to do some
negotiating and go to the heads of both
departments which are very small they're
two of the smallest apartments at
Harvard and I said you can't afford to
lose bodies let me study both of you and
then everyone wins so they did uh they
did let me study both of them but only
after I gave a list of potential thesis
topics that I could write because when
you do a double major at Harvard you
have to write a thesis that sits at the
intersection of your two Fields what I
ended up doing was writing a science
fiction novel that was set on a real
exoplanet that I studied Aid I
characterized it with data with data
from Kepler and I Kepler mission to find
exoplanets right so we have very good
data set there yeah I had well it was K2
so the data was a bit noisier than from
the Kepler primary Mission but the plot
of the novel was kind of an allegory or
um like a parallel to the Hawaiian
sovereignty movement I got to go to
Hawaii I talked to the protectors the
people demonstrating on Mauna Kea when
the 30 meter telescope conflict was
happening and that was a really fun
project but I it's taken me many years
wait you're in the middle of total
cultural turbulence and it was a fun
project for you yes okay I like talking
to people I like hearing theirselves
yeah just to catch some people up on
that so the largest the plans to build
the largest telescope in the world in
the best observing site of the world
which is in the big island of Hawaii uh
met resistance from indigenous
communities who viewed the mountain at
sacred in a way that would should not
allow this kind of construction and so
it was very it's fascinating cultural
political confrontations that unfolded
and you just drop yourself in the middle
of it damn well when I was a senior in
college was when it was really frothing
you know that conflict was extremely in
the news at least for the astronomy
community so you wrote a you wrote a
novel interesting as as in in as a in
place of but that was your thesis the
novel it was my thesis yeah I had the
creative part and then I also had an
appendix with all of my research notes
that's a brilliant a Brilliance to it
way to stitch those two together uh
thank you so much was that published
no I it's it's in a Google drive
somewhere up on my website somebody's
got to make a movie out of that wait I
mean all Hollywood
if anyone wants to approach me for TV or
movie rights to lying hordes please
please let me know yes definitely we'll
make that happen and you have another
book
do yeah that this book you're just out
of control you know latest I you know
busy okay all right go on um
the latest book is called the Milky Way
an autobiography of our galaxy please
pay close attention to that word
autobiography because this entire book
is written from the point of view of our
Milky Way galaxy
um it tells its story from its birth to
you know what might happen when the
universe ends it talks about its life
um it's adolescence and how it feels to
make stars it talks about the the
galactic neighbors that it has wait a
minute how about the collision with
Andromeda what does that feel like
it hasn't happened yet so the Milky Way
is oh it's only an autobiography up to
today up to today yeah um
with Andromeda how does it feel about
that oh it is quite excited
um in the book I I frame Galactic
mergers as like romance almost or or you
know like interpersonal relationships
and so there are minor mergers and major
mergers minor mergers happen between
galaxies where one is much more massive
than the other so I so it's basically it
says little flings wait wait wait so we
those who study this call that Galactic
cannibalism when a big Galaxy eats a
little one but you're calling them
romances that's that's such a different
take on the situation you know you know
what Neil why do the two have to be
mutually exclusive like some sometimes
the galaxies are eating each other and
at the same time it's romantic so like
whatever sometimes
sometimes the female eats the male
afterwards you know it's like yeah yeah
it's like galaxies are just praying
mantises
but no via the merger the eventual
merger between Andromeda and the Milky
Way will be a major merger because their
masses are much more similar and that's
more like a marriage
um so for billions of years the Milky
Way and Andromeda have had this long
term courtship they've been sending love
notes back and forth to each other in
the form of hyper velocity Stars where
they encode their messages into the
Spectra of the stars and it's very nerdy
and very cute wow wow okay so this just
came out in 2021 is that correct 2022
just a few months ago oh this came out
oh mid 2022 just just to emerge from
covid very nice okay so we'll look for
that damn
yeah okay that's a good story it's very
sassy I feel like I should Prime people
the Milky Way has a healthy ego and some
might say it's a little condescending to
us humans but like who who wouldn't be
who wouldn't be every alien would be
condescending yeah exactly clearly the
case clearly and one last question so we
got your astrophysics we got your
folklore and what about your science
communication science education part
um what what do you think is missing
that you can bring to it
ooh I think the folklore connections
that I can help people make are really
important
um because I I know that people will
feel better about learning science if
they can connect to it personally and
one of the strongest personal
connections yeah culturally or
personally I was getting there like the
the cultural connection is a great way
to make it feel more personal
um people might grow up hearing stories
and legends and myths from their from
their grandparents from their uh from
their elders and if you can learn about
science and tuck it into what you've
already heard from your people then it
makes it a lot more a lot more familiar
got it got it so that's a gap that needs
filling very good yeah I think yeah and
I'm not I'm not a comedian like Matt but
I think that sometimes I can make people
laugh and so I try to bring that into my
cycom too there's been some movement
within planetariums to do that
especially in planetariums that have
access to indigenous communities in the
south Southwest in Australia if you go
to Australian planetariums there's a
Aboriginal storytelling that's often
folded in to to the show so they have
such beautiful stories I mean they they
have cave paintings and cultural
evidence and and like oral storytelling
that talks about astronomy going back
like 60 000 years yeah really yeah old
knowledge there's a book called Dark emu
do you know about that dark oh I haven't
heard about the book but I do know about
the Emu constellation yeah the Emu the
dark emo so mad I hope you know about
this the in the sky the Western cultures
typically describe what they see based
on the existence of a star in a pattern
or sources of light but if you look at
the dark Lanes within our own galaxy The
Milky Way across the sky there's a
stretch of Darkness that looks like an
emu okay so so it's the absence of Life
they go by the negative the shape of the
negative space rather than the shape
yeah negative space uh a thing up there
the look of the stars because you know
like you say it was the thing that was
accessible always but in more accessible
then than it was now because I I grew up
in London we were talking about this
just before the show and you both live
in New York now and if you look up you
don't see much in the way of stars uh on
account of all the light but
you have to artificially build it in a
building inside the city but correct the
first few times I've been somewhere like
you know I've been to like a mountainous
place or a desert so someone that's
really in the middle of nowhere and then
suddenly looked up on a clear night and
just gone oh now I get why they were
always writing poems and and songs and
like this is suddenly this blanket of
stars that looks true because when I
grow up it's like oh yeah there's a star
there's another star there's another
star and then you go somewhere that's
properly remote like it would have been
everywhere thousands of years you're not
assaulted by the sky it's just kind of
suddenly yeah it is it's absurd good
it's this this thing that appears after
Nightfall is ridiculous
and it's I I think the number the last
number I saw was that 80 of the sky is
affected by light and air pollution now
so 80 of people around the world are not
seeing the same sky that our ancestors
saw and that that makes me really sad
because I think that makes people lose a
big point of connection that we could
have with the universe the cosmic
connection well this is supposed to be
Cosmic queries and so but I delighted in
learning everything about you there more
yes so that when the questions come in
well I mean people were queued that you
were going to Be Our Guest and with that
expertise so Matt uh load up the
questions and we're going to take all
right and when we come back we're going
to Dive Right In to Moya materia's
expertise astrophysics and folklore when
Star Talk returns
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries we're
talking about astrophysics and folklore
with Moya mcteer who studied both in
college and professionally and she is
now a freelance podcaster and
Communicator author of a book
the Milky Way and autobiography of our
galaxy written by the Milky Way itself
because because Matt she's the Milky Way
Whisperer right she's yes
what the Milky Way feels and actually if
you uh if you look at the title page it
doesn't say by Moya mctear it just says
via I'd merely that's right you were
just a channel perfect perfect
Publishers can go along with that with
that yeah
the vote written by the Milky Way with
its Galaxy sized brain there you go
there you go so let's bring we're Cosmic
queries Matt from our patreon supporters
yeah well this is the questions are this
is again because of the subject matter
uh the questions are all over the places
and straight astronomy questions and
there's some folk Warrior questions I'm
going to start with this one because it
ties into what we were talking about
just before the end of the first segment
Stephen Murphy from Atlanta says
constellations have always been a good
way to identify where stars are but they
are hard to remember in teaching the
modern world where few know Latin and
mythology can Ursa Major just be the Big
Bear would you make the Archer Hawkeye
instead of Sagittarius it would take
some getting used to but so did Pluto
not being a planet oh I love it I love
it oh wow so so Moya I'm gonna rephrase
that question to ask you why don't we
just update all the constellations to to
Modern
mythologies or modern things we care
about that's a great question you have
like you're gonna have to uh there's
some con this I've checked this because
I like ice cream there's some that looks
like an ice cream cone and so we have
conus major and conus minor for example
or have like the smartphone for any
rectangle that's up there so what do you
say about uh why are we so anchored to
what people were thinking 2000 years ago
why'd it make it relevant to today
oh God there's so much here
um so first of all if you want to start
renaming the constellations you have to
take it up with the iau the
international astronomical Union they
are this organization that's in charge
of naming stuff officially in space and
they have designated 88 official
constellations in the sky and and I I
emphasized official there because
there's a difference between
constellations and asterisms to a modern
astrophysicist a constellation is the
region of the sky like the physical area
that we have broken up the sky into and
there are 88 of those asterisms are the
shapes that you can make by connecting
dots between the stars and there are an
infinite number of those so you can
choose to rename your constellations you
can choose to to focus on conus major or
minor you can can make an iPhone
constellation
um you you can just draw no no you know
Samsung
would get into that because they make
the Samsung Galaxy Galaxy yeah they
would love that that's like a total
sponsoring opportunity for a new
Constellation Drive but go on yeah but
but I mean make up your own
constellations I think that that would
be a really cute
date idea or just like something to do
with your friends go out stargazing and
come up with new names and new
constellations and new stories to go
along with them but the constellations
that we do have the asterisms that we
mostly talk about today come to us from
Greek mythology and so they have these 2
000 years worth of traction like they
have dug themselves into our cultural
memory and before that they came from
Babylonians
um the like the crab and the the bull
constellations both just pulled right
from their cancer yeah okay yeah yeah
um so even the Greeks were using more
ancient constellations and asterisms uh
than what they were making up so I think
we're just following in the grand
tradition of using the names that have
come before us because it would be
really difficult if everyone actually
did come up with their own names you
wouldn't be able to talk about it but
you couldn't you wouldn't have the
shared you wouldn't have the shared
culture about exactly interesting
because a lot of them are you know the
ancient Greeks called constellations
catastarismoy which meant placed by the
gods they believed that a lot of these
constellations were messages
intentionally put into the Sky by their
deities to teach us whatever we needed
to know human ego just knows no bounds
dang life was rough two and three
thousand years ago it I imagine it was
pretty comforting to know that if you
lived a I don't know a heroic or at
least a notable enough life that maybe
the gods would put you immortalize You
by putting you into the sky as a
constellation that's what happened to
Orion so I have a fast constellation
story that hardly anyone knows it's not
that it's secret it's just hardly anyone
knows it when we rebuilt the rose Center
for Earth and space and we got our new
projector from Zeiss and they were going
to have the constellations built in that
you can turn on and off whatever
whenever you're showing the night sky we
use that in addition to our digital
projector that takes us anywhere in the
universe point is we create the 88
constellations we hired an artist to
give a modern
um a sensibility to the illustrations
yes it's still Hercules and it's still
Orion but it has he has a modern hand as
he draws it right it's not these the
these Renaissance curly constellations
that you might see in Old Maps anyhow
know that Gemini
in almost every met a constellation
illustration are shown as two infants
okay
two babies
because they're twins okay however in
Greek mythology they were like adults
okay they were like full-grown people
but the reason why they were always
drawn as babies is because the stars for
you to fully flesh out a human being
they have to be very close to each other
and the only way you could really pull
that off
is by drawing babies but the illustrator
was gay and he said I'm drawing two
full-grown men who are going to be
really close to each other on the sky so
so in the Hayden planetarium our Gemini
constellation are two full-grown men
like with overlapping shoulders arms
around each other and I love that so
much so so this was his his little you
know he didn't twist history he made it
real and just said let's try to put a
little awokeness into the night sky and
so that's in the Hayden planetariums
Star Theater I love that that's amazing
and one of the things we learned in
folklore is that every new telling of a
story every new priest rotation of of
this folkloric knowledge is just as
valid as what came before it's not that
you're changing you're just you're
you're creating accreting yeah new new
insights yeah okay so let's so next one
Matt I love these keep them coming all
right well you mentioned Orion uh FX
Flynn says uh where do we know where
they're from I don't know where FX uh FX
is from but um
I was struck last week by the
Magnificent site of Mars atop Orion as
it laid yourself oh here we go it is
actually mentioned in the thing as it
Luke as it laid you south of my location
in Vermont so not too far just up the
road from you during the wee hours of
the morning God of War above the hunter
I immediately wondered if this
combination featured in any of the Inca
histories we've collected uh you know
William Sullivan's secret of the Incas
myth astronomy and the war against time
here's hoping this particular
combination is only remembered for its
dramatic combination of bright red
orange and bluish white points of light
and nothing else so is uh I love that so
so the question I think Moya would be it
was Orion a hunter in other cultures or
because and is Mars the god of war and
other cultures
that's a great question because
juxtaposed on the sky you know that
could mean War right I mean yeah yeah
the God of War over the hunter in a lot
of cultures
um
remember not all cultures are going to
place the the stars that we associate
with Orion into the same constellation
so I I know that there are there are
cultures in South America where the
three stars of Orion's Belt are like
three brothers fishing in a canoe
together very different
yeah with Orion the hunter I mean
they're still hunting
but I just I I love that in every
culture still wherever they are on
growing up in completely different sides
of the world independently they've still
thought to just look at the stars and go
and draw pictures between them draw yeah
yeah what are they what patterns do they
make I mean it was the main source of
entertainment that we've had for
billions they didn't have HBO right yeah
you know streaming services I guess it's
the same as liquid clouds but the clouds
these clouds don't move these clouds
stay the same every night correct they
do they do move I mean they would they
would look at the differences between
the the fixed and the moving stars
actually so the the stars in Orion those
would be fixed because they're moving
with each other as as a whole
um and it does really look like the sky
is spinning around the Earth but then
there are there are wandering stars
um which is where our word planet comes
from because the planets and the moon
and the sun were these points of light
that appeared to move relative to all
the stuff in the background like Mars
would have been a Wandering Star
um so no not every culture saw Orion as
a hunter although many of them did if
they could see the Pleiades that's
that's an interesting thing because so
many cultures around the world saw the
Pleiades this little cluster of seven
stars as like seven sisters or seven I
don't know swans like the they they
Associated them with very feminine
qualities and because Orion is pointing
towards the Pleiades a lot of them also
said that like Orion was hunting those
sister wow you have to think about the
fact that not everyone in the world is
going to see constellations the same way
depending on where you are you might not
be able to see constellations but or if
you're on drugs that you'll see them
yeah not everybody
I'm certain that the Greeks were on
something for half the constellations
that they named oh my God they must have
been they must have been oh Mom well
back then I'm sure we're doing so many
drugs that's that's my head Canon for
the ancient world
here's a question for you Pegasus a very
Northern constellation for us to make a
horse out of it is actually upside down
so we knowingly made an upside down
constellation I'm just wondering in the
southern hemisphere did they what did
how do they they have because some are
upside down right so do they
think of upside down constellations or
is everything right side up to them
I don't know that for for specific
Southern cultures but I mean upside down
is just a matter of reference I I can't
imagine many cultures in the past would
have intentionally
assigned a constellation to be upside
down unless they had traveled to another
hemisphere so identified it as the same
group in a different orientation and
then went back and was like whoa they
see this differently right because
Pegasus does does look it's got some
stars that resemble the horse's head
it's got that angle in the in the arc
but it is completely upside down and
Pegasus the constellation Zone has only
room for half the horse so it's an
upside down flying half a horse and
somebody had to think that up I'm just
saying at least it's the front half yeah
better half yeah if it was a horse's ass
that's a whole other
look
that's a different mythology right there
totally different uh can I ask you a
quick question this is a question that
comes from uh Matt kirschen from Los
Angeles California oh wait are you a
patreon member is Matt kirchen a patreon
member I would check the files right now
all right yeah I'll give you a hall pass
for this one I just wanted to I I am I
right in thinking constellations
the the stars are not necessarily
anywhere near each other
or are they yes okay so they they look
short answer yes they so there is sort
of it there isn't a sort of astrophysics
relevance to constellations other than
helping to know where things are like uh
because the two stars could be in
completely different clusters that's a
great question right because I I think
Moya that would be a a naive if you just
approach this whole subject naively you
would say this is a constellation it
must be something scientifically
relevant about this area of the sky
right I mean why wouldn't anyone think
that
if you don't spend a lot of time
thinking about the three-dimensional
nature of space it is really easy to
assume that this this Tableau of
pictures we see in our night sky is made
up of stars that are all physically
clustered together but there is that
third dimension of distance that we have
to think about so the Stars might look
close to each other in 2D but they might
be very distant from each other in that
third dimension except for the Pleiades
which you mentioned which is a cluster
that's an actual it is a cluster yeah
that's true I did a research project in
grad school on identifying moving groups
of stars by their chemistry and we we
looked at the Pleiades cluster
um right so in rare cases they are
related but that's not those are the
exceptions right yes most of the time
they are yeah separate so that question
was from Matt kirschen of Los Angeles is
that correct yeah and I'm sure Matt's
very grateful for that answer
squeeze in this quick question because
you mentioned the Ancients being on on
substances and Gina Martin from North
Carolina and I just hit said I just hit
my THC pen so bear with me uh but Gina
wants to know about dark matter and
wonders if Dark Matter could actually be
the matter that escapes from black holes
uh the question that goes on for a
little bit but I'm just gonna cut it
short to there absolutely well let's
hold that for their break uh we're gonna
take a quick break when we come back
segment three uh astrophysics and
folklore on Star talk with our expert
Moya mcteer when we come back
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
Maury mcteer knocking it out with uh
what we're trying to find out how people
think about the night sky and what the
relevance of that is to science and
culture with Matt Kershaw and Moya what
where where do we find you on social
media
I've made it easy
I know my name isn't that easy to spell
uh I'm go Astro Mo on everything go
Astro Mo whoa yes
and I felt weird about it then but now I
kind of love it yeah yeah it's your it's
your moniker so Moya
m-o-i-y-a and mcteer is what it sounds
like but go Astro Mo I love it I love it
so let's let's keep this up oh one thing
I wanted to add to that previous uh
segment uh when the when the questioner
commented on Orion and and Mars which
was implicit there is that the star
Betelgeuse which is Orion's upper
shoulder is a red giant star so you have
the red Hue of that star near the red
Hue of Mars and so I think that's
contributed to the to the thrust of that
question because there's a lot of action
red action over in that part of the sky
and we all know that red means angry
yeah yeah
Sky then the gods are angry exactly
exactly all right Matt keep them coming
oh so she's just before the break Gina
wanted to know about dark matter and
whether it could actually be the matter
that escapes from black holes oh and
then yeah and then the THC started to
kick in and the question continues
wow Tina I hope you're having a great
time and I'm gonna tell you we don't
know what dark matter is either as
scientists we have a lot of hypotheses
there are things we're trying to test
out but most of what we know about dark
matter is how it behaves not what it's
made of we know that dark matter is
something that can interact with other
stuff gravitationally so it can you can
feel this gravitational tug but it
doesn't interact with light so you can't
see it you can't touch it you can't uh
you know if you shine a light through it
the light's just not gonna know it's
there
um is it stuff coming out of black holes
probably probably not I'm gonna I'll
tell you now that is not one of the
leading hypotheses
um there there there were people
several decades ago who thought maybe
Dark Matter was just a bunch of little
black holes because we can't see black
holes but they also interact with stuff
gravitationally so maybe dark matter is
just like a big clump of tiny little
black holes
but it doesn't seem like that's likely
all right plus if they were coming out
of black holes the mass of a black hole
would be dropping and we don't really
see that either right right and so that
was a question that came out under the
influence of THC yeah but I think I
think it was pretty good and also just
while we're talking about black holes
Molly Jepson says who's an American
University student living in Paris says
I'm fascinated by white holes and I
recently read that a white white whole
Singularity exists in the future and a
black hole Singularity exists in the
past what does that mean
was THC involved in that question too
yeah that's what sounds like it it was
not Molly was a specific as to what was
influencing that question it could have
just been a sheer wonder of the universe
yes that is th a force of THC unto
itself right the wonder wonder of the
universe so Maury what do you know about
white holes I know very little about
white holes I was just gonna say we're
beyond my realm of experts all I know is
it's like a mathematical opposite of a
black hole yeah yeah and if a black
holes uh you know absorbs everything or
brings everything in not actively it's
not like a vacuum sucking but uh if
that's what a black hole does then a
white hole should be the opposite it uh
it's where stuff comes out wait Moya
someone once told me that there's no
such thing as gravity Earth sucks and I
believe that are you saying are you
trying to disavow me of this
understanding of gravity come on now I I
like to hold multiple truths in my head
at the same time so
all right all right Matt keep going all
right well I'm going to combine these
two questions so I think this is getting
back more on to home territory for both
of you so Marcus Gustafson from Sweden
uh and also Dylan who's a physics
undergrad between the two of them ask
what are the methods used to map the
size of the Milky Way and where we are
located where are we located within it
and also Dylan who's the physics
undergrad said I'm wondering how we map
the Milky Way how do we observe
something if we're currently in it do we
just assume our looks from other
galaxies
wow yeah plus Moya every Star we see in
the night sky is in the Milky Way right
so tell us what's going on there I mean
we colloquially we say see that band of
light that's the Milky Way as though
that's something separate from the stars
that are around us so once you unpack
that for everybody
a lot in my new podcast pale blue pod is
that we are not separate from space it's
not that we're here on Earth and then
there's the Milky Way Out There we are a
part of the Milky Way the Earth is a
part of it we are a part of it um so I
just wanted to get that out there first
about oh mapping the Milky Way that's
something we've been trying to do for
hundreds of years
um I do think it's really interesting
that we only realized there were other
galaxies out there a hundred years ago
the great debate in the 1920s was all
about uh are we alone or are there other
Island universes and it turns out there
are so that's recent but we did know
that we're just in a collection that was
Island Universe used in the context of a
galaxy of other galaxies yes not as a
separate not in the Multiverse sense
right correct right yes they were not
having a great debate about the
Multiverse yes in the 1920s
um but we did know long before that that
we were in this collection of bright
points of light and so the earliest map
of the Milky Way was done by the
Herschel siblings Caroline and William
and that was back in the 1600s where
they they made some very simplifying
inaccurate assumptions that one they
could see all of the stars in the Milky
Way We Now know that we can't we
actually can't see most of the stars in
the Milky Way and that we were in the
center of it like they did they assumed
we were in the center of it so what they
did was was look out at the night sky
and map the bright Points of Light
um assuming that they were all like the
same size and so they tried to figure
out the distance to them uh using their
brightness because they were all the
same size again lots of very bad
simplifying assumptions but they came up
with this map of the Milky Way that just
looks awful but I encourage you to look
it up that was the first attempt these
days what we're doing doing is using a
much stronger telescopes and much better
assumptions about how things should be
distributed throughout the Milky Way
we've made observations of other spiral
galaxies so we have an idea of what the
rough shape should be
um but you're right it is pretty hard to
take a picture of a house when you're
inside it like we don't it's hard for us
to get a full view of what the Milky Way
looks like but we have models we have
telescopes that can see through the dust
so we now have a better view of the
center of the Milky Way we know where we
are in the Milky Way because we can see
that there is more light in One
Direction than there is in the other
um so yeah it's a matter of meticulous
mapping over time and trying to make
sure our assumptions aren't as wild as
they were in the 1600s is it as hard as
an unborn child figuring out what his
mother looks like
I think it's easier than that
um okay I do think because there's they
need like remote mirrors you know to
look outside you know because I think
that they're they're like the baby the
unborn baby could learn about the
distribution of organs but it would have
no idea what like the mother's face
looked like okay I I feel like we have a
pretty good understanding of what the
Milky Way's face looks like
um because there's not much variation
really when you when you boil it down to
the different
body parts of a galaxy there's there's
not that much diversity so we have a
pretty good idea right cool all right
Matt keep it coming all right well we
have I have a question we have a
question I mean depending how many
questions you have I might want to go
into lightning mode and this will put
Moya to the test see if she does she
have sound bites in her this is like the
great test of the educator
if we go into lightning mode I'm gonna
have to do some editing on some of these
questions because this is a this is a
subject that people have gone deep on
with the questions people have really
like people are written like many essays
and uh they've babbled on and on about
it okay well they're very excited about
it but uh so
the artist formerly known as James Smith
from Indianapolis I remember that name
from previous episodes it says Dr Moya
astrology astrology is a very popular
subject these days I think it's I think
it's fair to say there is a popular
subject all day is it uh but James says
do people believe that the stars are
influencing their lives because of
tradition or do you think it's because
they have something to blame their
rational behaviors or even their great
luck on who were the first to see the
stars for more than what they truly are
I I'd actually say for less than they
really are as well but I love that
question and and Moya wouldn't modern
astrology be considered folklore in New
York by your definitions I do I do
consider it folklore uh we are creating
folklore and mythology in the modern day
uh I think both of those reasons
resonate with a lot of astrology
practitioners uh people who follow it
um they need something to reason they
have been told that the Stars dictates
events in their lives and I think it's
very comforting for them I think a lot
of people use it as a way to feel
connected to the universe larger than
ourselves
okay so as a scientist it's I don't I
don't follow it I don't believe in it as
a folklorist I love looking back at
ancient astrology to see the real and
practical ways that humans knew the sky
did dictate their lives okay so do you
would you would distinguish then
astrologers of 500 years ago who didn't
know any better and that was like the
best way to account for their reality
versus today where we actually do know
better yet they're still doing it yes I
would distinguish them
um I think that ancient astrology was
extremely practical it had to do with
when were you planting your crops when
were you moving because of seasonal
flooding and stuff like that there were
also people who read
information from the sky that was less
practical
um I I think it's pretty agreed upon by
folklorists now that ancient Babylonians
were among the first to not just track
the motion of stuff in the sky but to
assign Divine meaning to it by which I
mean they had priests they had
astrologer priests who spent their lives
learning how stuff in the sky moved
because that was their way of
interpreting the will of their gods and
there was an eclipse or something they
wouldn't go to war or if there if there
was some alignment of planets of these
wandering stars in the sky then that
would tell them how they how they needed
to make I don't know government
decisions in that time Matt you think
that'd be a badass business card
astrologer priest and astrophysicist
that's that you know you're in charge of
everything at that point
that's kind of the business card I have
people assume that because I studied the
universe and because I studied folklore
that I just didn't know how everything
yeah you're just totally plugged into
everything that matters you're a
scientist we gotta totally do lightning
around here's the test go next question
I'm gonna have to summarize this
question because Edwin J roll down from
Lancaster Pennsylvania asks what's your
opinion on whether the next Mars mission
should have life detection experiments
on it
45 years ago there were some ambiguous
results from the Viking Landers and so
uh you you think about exoplanets a lot
more yeah and if you think of Mars as a
kind of an exoplanet because we're
looking and we might have life except we
can also go there
um what do you think should be the
priorities for for the upcoming Rovers
yeah I think that if there was kind of
Cloudy evidence before let's try and
clarify that evidence Cloud
um as long as there aren't other
instruments that would do better science
if it's not going to take up space then
yeah let's put something on there that
could um try and detect
more directly evidence of Life all right
I like that keep going Matt all right
I'm combining another couple of long
questions and I'm going to cut them way
uh very short Jim from Brooklyn and also
James Bennett both asking about photons
coming from Stars so uh where James says
where does the energy of the photons go
that have been redshifted due to the
expansion of the universe and Jim wants
to know
um if I stand out in the dark I can see
Vega shining brightly photons from Vega
are hitting my retinas but it's also
true if I'm 10 feet from my left 30
miles south of sea or floating in into
Stellar space
um so all these photons are coming from
the same star so basically how many of
these photos are coming off this seems a
lot of photons and what's the deal with
that and it goes on to questions about
dark energy and matter but I think
you've answered that already there's a
million photons so many photons
um one of my favorite things about light
is that it's isotropic if you have a
source of light photons are going to be
coming off of it in all directions and
as they spread out they're still going
to hit you even if you're 10 feet to the
left or somewhere in the middle of the
ocean it's all one of the millions of
photons coming from that same star
Millions so many photons
um I feel like that is very separate
from the first question you asked so the
first question was what happens to the
energy of the redshifted photons yeah
um I mean
so the the redshift of the universe only
happens on very large scales when we're
talking about Vega or other stars within
our own Galaxy that we're seeing they
are not being red shifted away from us
because of the expansion of the universe
it's light from very distant galaxies
that are being red shifted from the
expansion of the universe Neil do you
want to talk about where that energy
goes oh yeah sure there's still the same
amount of energy it's just now diluted
okay so the total energy is still there
but it's now spread over a much larger
volume and so when you dilute the energy
the photon you detect okay has has lower
energy but the total energy of all of
space Remains the Same from what had
been
put into it from the beginning so it's
so we have we think of energy density in
the way you can think of matter density
have some things are more dense than
others you know a brick is denser than a
than a balloon so when you stretch out
the Universe
um things just get less energy dense
but you're not losing any energy to some
secret place
it's more diffuse there you go uh let's
try one more yeah I've saved this
question for last uh all right Matt go
for it uh so Sandra pagliani who who
like many of the questions says nice
things about the podcast first and then
says can you possibly explain can we
hear the nice things I want to hear the
nice things
just skip over that okay
said my favorite podcast of all time uh
the someone else who I can't remember
now says thank you for all the science
and the humor that the people to say
people say lovely things about you I uh
and and the show okay I think they're
doing it just to get their question
answered see you say nice you say maybe
one strategy but
Sandra says could you possibly explain
ghosts with physics since we can only
perceive a specific range of the
frequency spectrums when it comes to
sound of the light we base our reality
on these limitations could it be that
what we call quote ghosts is residual
energy from past that is reaching us now
filtering into our current state of
reality for a brief moment frequencies
can create resonances of various
harmonic intervals so some of those
frequencies can be picked up by humans
dot dot dot possibly wow
aren't they part of folklore I mean
those are absolutely part of folklore
yes look I I have never learned anything
in any of my science classes that told
me ghosts couldn't exist
oh oh I see what you did there oh
there's not a chapter why ghosts don't
exist in anybody I've never read that
textbook
[Music]
um but
I I like I said before I like to hold
two truths in my mind at the same time I
I would love a world where ghosts and
magic and these other folklore things
exist that's why I study them I like to
inhabit that World
um science can't explain most of that
yet
so maybe one day there will be a
textbook that says definitively whether
or not ghosts exist because of physics
but until I read that that book
science is real and also ghosts could
happen
oh okay
what about Frankenstein's
oh that is that is science yes what
about the Invisible Man what about
vampires what about yeah the list I got
a list ready to come into this I mean
they're specifically calling it
Frankensteins just to annoy the many
pendants who listen to this show
yeah get away from the Frankenstein
versus Frankenstein's monster thing
um yeah Frankenstein was just a human he
was just a scientist so yeah that exists
Dr Frankenstein yes
there actually are some very interesting
scientific ties to the origin of a lot
of these folkloric figures I've been
listening to some podcasts recently
about uh where the various
myths about vampires came from because
there are there are animals that suck
blood there are animals that will dig up
Graves uh there are reasons why you
might find these stories very present
throughout the world with natural causes
is what you're saying yeah exactly right
I mean this is so I I didn't get a
chance to say this in the first segment
but the main interest I have in this
intersection between science and
folklore is that I really do believe
there are two sides of the same coin and
that coin is something you can buy
understanding of the universe with
people weren't just making up stories
for the fun of it most of the time
ancient humans were observing the world
around them and coming up with
explanations that fit into their world
view and as we scientifically progressed
and we gained tools and we had
accumulated knowledge over thousands of
years then our worldview shifted away
from Magic and and gods and folklore but
the there's still use there's still
value in the stories and the
observations that people made
so what you should do is write a book of
today's folklore
that one day science will have something
to say about about yeah I'd love that
yeah all the little superstitions 100
years the scientists will be like oh
that's why that happens all right well
we'll hope to get you back on this show
before 100 years from now
please
when we have that Moya it's been a
delight to finally meet you all right
Matt great to have you here oh it's
great to be here you've been watching
possibly listening to StarTalk Cosmic
queries our folklore Edition
loving it I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson you're
a personal assistant
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]